what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
player stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion
vayan is not sleeping we're just giving
other teams and Bundesliga head start I
dress in all black because every game is
a funeral for the other team right now
this show is good people are happy to
wait until season 3 things will go very
bad
[Music]
now you see it now you don't regard
obrigado a hatchet radiators I could do
that for my final trick I need two
volunteers for Mosul everybody puts cash
winner anyone else I'll do it okay come
on I've got a very bad feeling about
this
please dim the lights purnima and now
let me see can mo go from bucks a police
I would like to leave this box no
problem man mouth even Kira
oh my god good I'm so sorry I don't know
what happened can you separate us I'm
not the doctor I I can what do you mean
you caused this you fix this
so did you bit nice you catch more flies
with honey than Oh what you listen okay
if you don't use your little magician
magic to fix this then I'm going to make
you disappear Kay
I'm just a little magician okay not a
big magician you need a real sorcerer
take this bro holy Porto Alegre the
great warlock he has tortured me in the
past and to this day it still gives me
nightmares it sounds cool to me this
place gives me the creeps man maybe we
should just go see a normal doctor Oh
mr. tough guy is shaking in his boots
listen you don't know what this which is
capable of okay oh well whatever it is I
got them in this house oh great gene
will seek your help
I Ronaldinho would be happy to help you
oh we would be most grateful if you
could separate us if there is anyone in
this whole world who knows about getting
separation from Sergio Ramos it's me
baby
okay let me see here is definitely a
curse the curse the curse but the good
news is that this curse is a lot like
Sergio it's very easy to break through
sorry
make sure that is kind of a dick Ramos
doesn't scare me his violence is a
compliment it's his way of letting you
know he can't stop you oh is that right
don't you make me break your other
shoulder you one season wonder at least
I'm not a cheater future of you two
listen it seems that when continue did
his incantation he didn't account for
your animosity towards each other you
can't have hatred in your soul when you
go box to box I learned this lesson well
as a man who has two wives I can tell
you but don't worry it's very easy to
fix these curse will be lifted when you
sergio apologize tomorrow for injuring
his shoulder and all you have to do mo
is simply forgive Sergio nah forget it
not worth it
[Music]
[Music]